[Music]
Yeah Yeah Yeah .ne.jp b Goods [Music] teame
dee
Oops
[Music]
2d We finally announced the completely new Metroid Dread
of Metroid, starting with Metroid in 1986 and
with Lloyd's Super Metroid
Metroid Fusion  The latest car and the latest episode in the series that has continued for the first time in 29 years The
Metroid series is a game that depicts the activities of a female bounty hunter
named Sams Alan.  In
the
[Music]
series, I wrote about the relationship between Metroid and the main character Samst, but this time
it's an episode that is a secret seller of the story. I imagine that
there is one country for series fans.
The
story is important, but it's not just a game for fans.
Basically, it's an interpreter and a game. The
strongest sake in the galaxy.
I think that if you watch the professional armor of the game,
it does not mean that you do not understand the story
. Rather, there is also a way to enjoy it because this work is the first Metroid person.
I
want to express the desperate fear of the enemy's South Alarm. Now, money is an overwhelming existence that is based only on the idea of acting alone on a planet that has n
ver been used.
Actually, I came up with the idea of Metroid Dread about 10 years ago. Howev
r, I thought that the technology at that time couldn't express the concept well, but unfortunately I gave up and had a
chance to try again after that.
I thought that it was unlikely that the game would be put together as I imagined, so I
decided to give up again. To be honest, I was wondering if I would give up on this project, but it was
too cold for 3ds ds.
Steam Entertainment was a very good team. I had
a good sense of skill and a good sense of
the game.
I was convinced that Dodred would definitely be completed, and
more than I envisioned 15 years ago, Metroid was completed in this way. In a
word, Emmy who appears this time is really scary.
I'm just
wandering around in a particular zone, Mr. Carne senses the sound of him and puts it underground. When
it's seen by a comparison sensor, he goes out to the enzyme to catch it.
Samus's normal loop is  I hear everything,
and the skewer that spills when caught This is tough.
Carbon has to carry out the mission while fighting such fear.
This time it is even more difficult. It
is a very disadvantageous situation for Samus, but within the detection range.  If you don't make a cry,
Emmy will notice it.
That's why you can hide it.
And the representative of the course team that you want
is the optical camouflage ability that the source is from Emmy and the version is quark.
How to use this  However, I think that the progress of the feast is adopted by the station
and acts so that it will not be found by the toothless enemy. I
think that it is a strong spice of the metroid body shape
.  You might think that the overall game design is a little bit, but don't
worry
, polish the gameplay of Moody Street for action and exploration
elements.
I made it easier to handle the dmm 0 counter etc. It
is a place called sliding as the temperature Aguchi small.
Action a is quite fulfilling, so the game experience is more comfortable. Of
course, even those who have never played Metroid
Lastly, I would like to briefly touch on the search elements that are in line with each other.
Lloyd is a carbon-type action English game. With
power-up abilities, Samus's actions are added more and more.
It's a mechanism that expands the range.
Power-up that has never been seen before. Naturally, I'm adding
Spider Magnus that can be held in a specific cafe or
heaven.
He has various things, so please look forward to it.
I think that searching with a high degree of freedom using various abilities is more than
ever.  Etro's dread is a fusion of two types of city council: comfortable action, free exploration and self-chased action
. You can enjoy it with or without cheese experience.
Newly designed Metroid Please wait a little longer
[  music]